greetings everyone
join here today
uh
so um yeah my name is alexander lutze
and i'm a research scientist and one of
the developer of the
nvidia nemo toolkit for conversational
ai
and today
we will
give a brief overview of this toolkit it
won't be like too
technical presentation if you want to
like ask me some tough technical
questions you can do it like in the qa
section
this won't be more of an overview
we'll talk about uh
like the toolkit overview in general
then where to start with nemo
then
uh
we will
discuss in more details
it's asr
which automatic speech recognition text
to speech and natural language personal
capabilities
then
finally we'll see how to
get nemo models from research to
production
and that would be it
so let's start
so again nvidia nemo toolkit is an open
source toolkit for conversational ai
when we talk about well at least when we
talk about conversational ai
i think about
three main things automatic speech
recognition natural language parsing
and speech synthesis for texas fish
this is the three main components
of the
conversational human computer
interaction
so the indian nemo toolkit is built
around these three
areas
so for automatic speech recognition we
can transcribe words
we can
do voice activity detection
we can identify the speaker we can
diarize and separate different speakers
in case of overlapping speech
we have quite
wide nlp capabilities with that
classification name and desire
recognition questions
yeah questions and answers and
and so on
and finally after that we can synthesize
speech to
uh generate an answer to a user
yeah apart from just the speech
synthesis we have a voice and intonation
control which is
quite
useful
uh in real life applications to make
like your speech synthesis more
expressive
so um
yep
uh
diving a bit more into technical details
the ingredient immortal kit is built
upon by torch and the pythos lightning
with by torch for well neural networks
and by torchlighting
to
run in the training of it sometimes
inference on scale
so uh the nema core builds um
on these two frameworks
and then we have uh
so-called collections libraries for the
specific tasks like srmp and tts
then for these collections we have
pre-trained models
and so with all this stack you can build
like your own uh speech applications
or nlp just enough yep
we have quite many
pre-trained models for many languages
like english minor russian spanish
german and so on for now unfortunately
we
do not support armenian
if you are interested why then ask me
this question
in the qa section
but i hope we'll be there
yep
we have quite plenty of sr and nlp tasks
at hand
like
translation big nlp and things like that
so
it can
automatically
check your
semantic when you program with
nemo
and
it performs quite well at scale i think
the nemo is the most robust uh
conversational ai toolkit
to run it on scale
we put like a lot of efforts
for this
yep uh so yeah
but of course it can be around like
multi-node and
multi gpu it supports quite many
uh
numerical formats like log 16
cf 32b flow 16 and so on
and yeah again it's an open source so
this is the link
and at the
[Music]
uh
the second slide was the uh
qr code so you can just try it so yeah
it's fully open sourced
great isn't it
so um why do you need it like at the
first place
like why don't you have this toolkit
well why not something else
uh
i just built around conversational ai
and
so it is made easy like to build and
customize conversational ai models uh
so
this is a one tool kit like for the five
like four
uh both like the whole pipeline like for
speech recognition understanding and
synthesis
you you can train your models like from
scratch or buy a transfer loaning and
i highly recommend you to do the second
because
it saves computation like tremendously
so um
yeah uh neural models actually nemo
states for neural modules
not the fish anymore uh
so uh it is a i mean they are flexible
building blocks uh they are quite
actually convenient to build like your
own systems with them
so um
yeah it again it has
uh
module collections
that are easy to use
so
you can easily integrate them with your
existing like
workflows
and uh it is also easy to export for
deployment which we'll talk later
so yeah this is the
just a simple pipeline like how to
how you do nemo so
you like
repost your data you set your encoder
and decoder models you said you lost
functions and then just
run the training it's quite simple
so um
yeah now to nemo collections uh i
mentioned this
quite a few times
so um
you can see it as a scripts and breathe
like a like a whole concept of scripts
scripts and pre-trained models
for uh
many conversational ai tasks
so um you can see like this we have sr
collections with quite many models and
loss functions
not only for speech recognition but also
for identification
we have a nlp collection
with
yeah this is probably a bit outdated we
now we have not only the bird model we
have plenty of them actually through the
big nlp concept uh
yeah it it it has some nice features
like hanging face indirect uh
integration and yeah
and stuff uh a bit less languages
right now for
like general nlp
it is a bit
harder to like fit the whole bunch of
nlp tasks
for now then for example sr yeah and the
ttcs again so we have
quite a mainstream things like a
targetron 2
fast paced waveglow
and
our own
things like talk net so um
yeah
so
again
modular uh all scripts and examples are
there
all pre-trained models are there you can
just use it like
easily and freely
so um what yeah it works
now actually like where to start with
this thing
yeah
so um
the
we have a concept of uh tutorials
so for example if someone familiar like
with toolkits like
kaldi or
espnet they have like recipes we have
tutorials
uh
it is uh
jupiter notebooks which can be
used locally on google's collab
um
like it has a quite um
like uh
white like covered area all the nemo so
we have general concepts like
with nemo fundamentals
then to how to construct your model how
to publish your model
then
for speech processing well
practically for everything you need
with the speech processing
for nlp and tts again
this qr code you can
just scan it and see
what is the contents
there so
the
link is here
that represents this qr code so yeah it
is tutorials they
quite easily though i'm expert for
example in automatic
recognition i still sometimes refer to
those tutorials
because they're great
and if you're like if you don't even
want to uh
like do nemo as a selfie you can just
use them like to uh just a starting
conversational ai that still would be
fine
so yeah i highly recommend you to try
this
so
then do
the automatic speech recognition
a bit
dive deeper to this topic
yeah actually
automatic speech recognition uh
well evolved quite
i would say huge
with time
so like in
[Music]
2020 we had like um
like
4.7
uh water rate so um yeah for um
automatic space recognition the word air
rate is the main metric of the model
accuracy or model quality
so um
for example like
uh we got like from uh
4.7
of the errors to
3.0 which is quite huge
so labor space this other it is probably
most like the most widely used uh the
most common uh test set to measure the
performance
of asr models so the
like
three percent over
it is actually i mean someone can say
that oh that this is still huge i mean
this is not practical it is practical
enough it is actually more than uh
well kind of
and it is beyond human parity so if you
for example would try to
uh
listen to this uh test set and try to
text what you heard you will probably
get a bit more than three percent of the
errors so
for such cases
we have
really like uh
superhuman performance here
apart from uh this kind of uh academic
example
we have quite many pre-trained models
for
many like commonly used languages
so yeah some
uh well
cdc-based introduces based architectures
here so cdc and transducer uh
sr losses
uh won't be dive
deeply there
so um yeah
apart from the neural network models as
in like to just recognize pitch as an
acoustic model we have language models
based on uh statistical engrams or
neural language models to
further improve the quality of the
speech recognition
uh we have self-supervised models if you
heard something about this concept
right now it's not
uh
not only wave to back 2.0 but our own
developments there
we have this nice concept of adapters
uh
so the concept of adapters
it is kind of an
next generation of fine-tuning so
instead of like
fine-tuning your data i mean fine-tuning
your operating models to your data
and uh facing like catastrophical
uh catastrophic forgetting problem you
can just use these adapters this
adapters are some kind of uh attachable
modules to your
like main module and you train actually
them and not the main model
and then you just concatenate the
results with your model just you know
as a simple addition
so um yeah
uh if you ever like uh
going to fine-tune your sr or whatever
nlp models i recommend you do this
through adapters
so um
yeah and soon we will have decorating
with double fistic graphs and the model
confidence estimation which is
also the important thing
for
robustness of the model
so um yeah let's
move further with
my little demo that i uh
recorded myself so uh yeah actually i
tried to break our model here and this
camera is in on hugging face so let's
let's see it
come on
yeah so i recorded my speech and then
type compute and so this is my speech it
is actually accurate i mean it is
exactly accurate uh besides the very
last
words pyramid is because
actually i blew it i pronounced it's not
so great
so the next one
yeah i
actually i like this double really well
because
first of all uh
it said that it can't recognize it so
and i pronounced cannot recognize it
said like can't recognize so
it was quite fun
so uh i'd just give later why
it happened and then uh words like
by data or year one was like completely
wrong
and
again this is one of the
flaws of this not not the model itself
but the inference so uh
inference in uh hug interface it is like
it runs just kind of a simple grid
decoding procedure without any language
model and for this
we actually
we do want to have a language model
because our model probably
just uh haven't heard this word like pi
data
i mean it probably should actually hurt
the year one but yeah with pi data
probably
this wasn't the training data so
it misrecognized it that's why actually
we need the language models
so uh yeah but again the model is great
i just really tried to break it and well
i succeed because i i know what i'm
doing
so anyway uh let's move further with
this so actually
how to run it like at your machine or at
a google collab i mean if you don't want
to use uh
uh
well
uh hugging face so yeah there's just
three simple uh lines of code here so
you
import your nemo asr
you initialize your model
by just passing the
name of the model here for now i mean
for this example it is a conformer
transducer extra large
and then you just run uh
sr model transcribe for
your data
and uh
that's it that would do it i mean at
least for a single file or for like um
for a notebook if you want to
uh
run transcribing of like many audio
files like in folder or something
you can do it like just from python
like this one
so call this script on skype sketch
uh provide your model name
and your audio data and that's it
it will do this trick
so yeah
quite simple interface i mean just the
three lines of code
uh
beyond automatic speech recognition
we have models like matchboxnet for
uh
speech commands or keyword spotting
then we have marble net for voice
activity detection most activity
detection is the thing that
that says whether
someone speaks right now or not like
whether there is a speech on a recording
or not special maybe some noise or maybe
just silence
so um it has text summarization and it
does text normalization it is a quite an
important thing for production actually
i mean
this is
not uh
like
it had little attention uh of academia
this field but for production you gotta
use it because
like
for example your model
will not for example produce you like
capital letters for example and you may
probably need it for your inference
because yeah people like capital letters
so uh for example inverse
text normalization does that
and texturalization used for speech
synthesis for example like when you
synthesize your uh data you just like
you type it
like as you are i mean just regularly
but
you have to like pre-process it for this
speech synthesis model like drop all
punctuation
uh
reduce capital letters and things like
that
maybe
uh transform
numbers
to words for example
so um yeah
and also we have
tools like this speech data explorer
this tools for data set creation and
analysis
it is quite convenient when you want to
analyze your speech data
so um yeah
you can
find it at the tools folder and try it
if you want to analyze your speech data
so um yeah now to tgs pipeline
so um yeah
uh our gts
or vector speech or speech synthesis is
quite
uh fast so we
drop tacatron 2 and we switch to uh
parallel known auto aggressive models
which is
uh actually important because like uh
everyone like in production
wants to
have like fast
speech well
yeah
fast pitch synthesis models
it is uh
robust
against uh duration
and
skipping and repeating words
it is express if you can control pitch
and the other parameters of
expressiveness
again it is easy to train and
i mean just as everyone as everything in
nemo
and
yeah we have uh
gun based
vocoders and plenty of spectrogram
generators here
so our mean
opinion score is quite good so uh i mean
opinion score is quite i mean it is how
uh
quality of text to speech is measured so
it is a human measured metric
so uh people listen to some recordings
of real
speech for example like this ground
through eight audio
and the synthesized speech and assigned
their kind of a
um their marks that their scores like
how natural it is
so uh
our for example fast pitch
models and model and mixer tts are quite
close to the ground through
of the expressiveness and naturalness
so yeah and it was quite
a few parameters
this is how
it looks like to
start with the
speech synthesis so a bit more uh
lines of code than for asr but still
like again we have
two models here one for generated
spectrogram and the one for uh
transforming this spectrum into actual
audio so spectrum generator and
vocoder
uh respectively
so yeah you load them
uh
you uh
generate a
with this for example phrase like hyper
data this is first pitch and hive again
dts from nemo
and then you convert your spectrum to
actual audio and save so let's try to
listen to it
yeah
not
that expressive i would say but this is
just because this is like this simple
example like
you could uh play a bit with the
expressiveness and uh
get like
uh
well
get a sound like like you want it
so um yeah then finally to
nlp
first of all let's talk about uh the
concept called big nlp i actually
borrowed this slide from
the last gtc conference of nvidia
um
so the concept of
big nlp is
to have like extremely
large
uh language model trained on some
enormous amounts of data
and well how to do this
effectively
so
and then you can do some uh quite
interesting things with such mods i mean
you probably
heard
some of them for example like
this is a joint megatron and um
nemo project of big nlp but you almost
probably heard like gpt3 models
uh something like this so they're quite
powerful and
actually they
so powerful that we can't even fathom
how they're powerful but we'll see about
that
so um
yeah
uh
why do we actually need large language
models mostly because
they are
few shots and zero shots
lowness
what does it mean
you can start just without like any
training data at all for your task and
just use those extremely large models i
mean
if of course if you can run them
so
you don't need data for like your
particular nlp task like at all
of course you can improve it with a few
examples then it will be a few short
learning
and also it's like one model to handle
all tasks so
you can train or even like hard code a
few heads for
this uh like one model and just
run inference for this one model and uh
have like full stack of your and obvious
capabilities with this
so um let's look at this
demonstration which i also borrowed
from gtc
it is about
omniverse if you heard this concept and
the project melon and
how we put
a big nlp model to actually
uh
well interact with the user
you in just a voice comments i mean
interact like uh in
to interpret um
the intention of the user and do as he
says he she they so
yeah
let's see
yes
like
the recommended colonies
changed
yay that's it
uh sorry for the recording being too
uh quiet
i don't know i'm not sure how to
oh
uh okay well anyway that was the last uh
demo so
yeah sorry i blew it uh
anyway
so what you just saw here is a
combination of
the three
this big
fields like asr
nlp well no you in fact what language
understanding
and the tts
combined in a one application
so the thing is we didn't like uh
hard code like the commands and the
answers we just kind of
wired uh
some uh
functionality like from some kind of a
base uh
like from ambience representation
representing the desired comments to
actual like
functionality of this application
and that's it so it is like completely
like zero shot learning i mean um
if we talk about the
uh
like uh intent classification or quant
uh question answering so it is great so
i mean you you can prototype and build
your own uh
uh conversational
based kind of applications i mean
applications with the conversational
capabilities just that easy
i mean that's cool i mean at least for
me
so um
then uh a bit
what can you do else with this um
large
language models so um
what you saw there uh it is called an
entailment
uh it is how it costs to
zero shot tasks
so um
you can do uh prompt engineering for
example so uh
like say you you have some task
but you don't have data for it
actually
you you can do some prompt engineering
to extract
like some generated but still quite
accurate and natural
sentences from such model and thus
generate
your training data just with prompt
engineering
then you can do
this
instructions tuning for example so
suppose you you have some taxonomy like
um
on this uh picture
with the yeah
uh nervous system drugs
uh
uh
cyclone analytics and things like that
so
you
have this
system and
you want to generate a trained data from
it so again you can do that
so
big nlp models can produce from i mean
can transfer this to this
to actual and quite
meaningful and
rational sentences
and prompting uh will be coming soon
probably maybe it's already there i
didn't check unfortunately
but yeah
uh the capabilities are quite
interesting and uh
this is a pirating shift shift indeed
so um
yeah of course
nemo has neural machine translation i
mean
who doesn't have it right now
so
it
the models of it are mostly transformer
based
uh like
you see here probably
the most uh well overused
uh figure from the
attention is all you need paper
uh also we have this receiver-based
encoders if you don't want to use just
transformers
so um
you can use pre-trained encoder encoders
from hugging face
in
into nemo like not only upload your
checkpoints to hug interface but
use some
external ones
inside of an email
you can choose of multiple tokenizers
like hacking facebook can either send
the speed stocking as you talking to me
or you can drop documents at all and use
byte level
encoding if you know what you're doing
so um
you can do fine tuning on your domain
specific tasks
uh
there are a
few uh multilingual models so many to
english and english to many
uh
again
just a billion will models quite
many of them but again unfortunately we
don't have uh
armenian for now
so um
and um again
uh other tasks oh five minutes thanks
so yeah uh
again
uh intent recognition
uh slot fail and docker
talking classification ventilation
question question answering and things
like that
so um
yeah
quite the
weight capabilities
we're almost done uh just only one slide
probably left
it is how to deploy your
nemo models okay say uh you have
if you are from academia you will be
probably interested
in this thing but if you are from
industry and you trained or just
downloaded your model so and you want to
run it then how to do it
not with nemo nemo is a
a bit more about
research but anyway we have another tool
called nvidia riva
it is an accelerated speech ai
sdk
it can be deployed like
everywhere
like
started from like
multi-cloud setups to
embedded solutions
it is not open sourced well some of the
this parts are closed some of them are
open sourced but it is
again free so i mean if you want like
enterprise is a great support you can
always buy an enterprise version but uh
mostly the riva is free
and
apart from deploying nemo models riva
itself has
its own
models they sometimes even better than
nemo models because they can use
proprietary data and
checkpoints from nemo uh trained
uh on
like open uh
so uh
on data with not prohibitive licenses
so um yeah and it supports streaming
it is kubernetes friendly
and yeah again it has support so
where to start it
you can
uh
look at the nvidia deep learning
institute
and
try to search that
their reverse pitch
api demo and
it will be there so you can try it
that's almost it but i think if i have a
just a minute uh i want to
promote you the next gtc conference
of nvidia
uh it is quite like
bright colorful
interesting
uh sometimes even breathtaking it's not
like in some
uh
i know your scientific conferences
uh it will be at late september so you
can scan this qr or you can google it
and
see it for free well i mean most of the
times
the those juices are quite fun thanks
[Applause]